here's what would happen if we drilled  through a volcano  this collapsed Bowl looking structure is  a volcano it's known as a Caldera its  magma chamber continues to fill up deep  underground until it's extremely  explosive and destructive at first  things would go smoothly drilling would  be happening on both sides of the  volcano and then water would be pumped  in from one side to flow out the other  side Not only would this cool the  volcano down but you could use the hot  water as an energy resource but then  you'd notice the ground shaking you  could hit a hydrothermal gas pocket  which would cause hydrogen sulfide to  escape this could trigger explosions  earthquakes or even a full-blown  eruption thousands of people could die  and it would take Earth decades to  recover from the damaging effects on a  climate so maybe drilling volcanoes  isn't the best idea because